hey guys welcome back to the real
Rejects My Name Is Sally AKA salamander
AKA Sila Monaco you can follow me on
everything if you have watched all the
videos on me till now thank you so much
I hope you enjoyed them this is
officially the beginning of phase two
I'm super excited kind of have a crush
on Robert Downey Jr now so I'm excited
to watch Iron Man 3 to kick it off but
before that we're gonna have a little
Chit Chat you're not in trouble um so I
filmed all of phase one basically in
this van of like two weeks I was told
just to go in with an open mind and kind
of be an average every man type person
so I apologize for not doing more
research I know I offended a few people
sorry just to give you a little back
story on me whether you know me or not I
was pursuing acting in Los Angeles and I
consider Los Angeles to be my home
because of covid I was completely
operated and had to leave it was not
something I wanted to do but honestly it
was something I definitely needed to do
I went from being very extroverted to
very introverted and I'm sure a lot of
you guys might able to relate when the
first video was published The Iron Man
reaction it did get taken down but it
hadn't even been up for a week already
before it already reached like 45 000
views and all the comments were so
positive and welcoming me back to the
channel and I got really emotional it
really means a lot like healed something
in me it meant a lot to me on some of my
reactions I'm not very um expressive
like it used to be I think because I've
just been so isolated here and I'm not
crying I'm not crying what do you mean
I'm crying oh I just want to make sure
that these videos are as fun for you as
they are for me and express that
properly because I don't express my
emotions as much as I feel like I should
anyway I'm sorry that was a long intro
and you caught me in my deals thank you
so please hit that subscribe button
please hit that like button and if you
want to watch the whole entire thing
with me with your own copy to sync up to
you can go to patreon.com the real
rejects without further Ado let's watch
Robert Downey Jr for like the fourth
time and I'm not mad about it
[Music]
famous man once said we create our own
demons
who said that what does that even mean
doesn't matter I said it because he said
it so now he was famous and basically
getting said by two well-known guys I
don't uh
I'm gonna start again
[Laughter]
ponies start great speech man I gave a
speech how was it edified unintelligible
really it's my favorite kind wedding
combo where are we going to town on each
other oh I have a proposal I'm putting
together myself it's a privately funded
Think Tank called Advanced idea
mechanics he reminds me of Electro and
The Amazing Spider-Man 2.
is he gonna be a villain
by the notion
of work yeah
for five minutes I'm just gonna try to
get my beef wet real quick he said
titillated in that man
[Music]
that
would scare me
come on
let's go to you
I would be
I'm the best
oh my God
you know who I am
you don't know where I am
and you'll never see me coming
so last time you got a good night's
sleep Einstein slept three hours a year
what's your name Aaron
I loved you in A Christmas Story by the
way
oh my God
cram are you okay
take it easy
no sign of cardiac anomaly or unusual
brain activity okay so I was poisoned
my diagnosis is that you've experienced
a severe anxiety attack
pepper
he got a glow up
we like to call extremists
[Applause]
that's the universe my bad but if I do
that
yeah galaxy stuff is so 2019
amazing thanks it's mine
what
this you're inside my head it's a it's a
live feed come on up I'll prove it
that's unfortunately to my ears it also
sounds highly weaponizable
something tells me now there's a new
genius on the throne who doesn't have to
answer to Tony anymore
it's gonna be a no Eldridge yeah you're
gonna build
it
[Music]
I want one you ate without me already on
date night well I finished up a little
work uh-huh and yes I had a quick bite I
didn't know if you were coming home or
you were having drinks with all this
Killian
what
threat is imminent and I have to protect
the one thing that I can't live without
that's you
and my suits they're uh
machines they're part of me
distraction
felt like a very real
coffee like that
Tony Tony
whoa what we're down
it's like a horror movie
you just traumatized here
girlfriend
I'm sorry buddy
what are you doing buddy
I would run
[Music]
help me
what is happening oh
my God like LA traffic isn't already bad
it's like a nuclear bomb I know this
must be getting frustrating but this
season of Terror is drawing to a close
and don't worry the big one is coming
your graduation
this is actually terrifying
it's too real
my name is Tony Stark and I'm not afraid
of you
there's no Pentagon it's just you and me
here's my home address
10 880 Malibu Point what are you doing
pepper pods lives with you oh he is
unhinged right now
guys
are we still at ding dong we're supposed
to be on total
security lockdown come on
I need to be alone with you someplace
not here it's urgent please don't
do
13.
frankly I don't think you'll last a week
I'll be fine
do we need to worry about that
oh my God oh my God oh my God
foreign
how did he do that
I got you
[Music]
the amount of times this house has been
blown up for like
completely ruined
[Music]
okay that girl is gonna need stitches
oh this is brutal
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Jarvis where's my flight power working
on it sir this is a prototype what is he
doing
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
that was my fear in the first movie
being submerged in the water in a big
metal heavy suit
stressed I'm gonna need Botox
what's up
oh that is so terrifying sir take a deep
breath
that's so cute
foreign
so I don't live in Malibu
okay that's the emergency alert
triggered by the power dropping below
five percent
[Music]
weight is wet and in the cold
foreign
where are we Upstate we have five mile
side of Rose Hill Tennessee
why
maybe I'll just cozy back up first I
actually think I need to sleep now sir
Jarvis
and so do you Mr Stark
Stark secure server now transferring to
all known receivers pepper it's me
a lot of apologies to make and not a lot
of time so I'm so sorry I put You In
Harm's Way that was selfish and stupid
I need to find this guy
you got to stay safe that's all I know
I just stole a poncho from a wooden
Indian
is that Iron Man technically I am
technically you're dead
with point if I was building Iron Man
and War Machine it's Iron Patriot now
that's way cooler no it's not
so uh who's home well my mom already
left for the diner and dad went to
7-Eleven to get scratchers
I guess he won because that was six
years ago which happens dad's leave no
need to be better
keep your appointment tonight call me
when it's done
all right everybody no talking and no
eye contact unless you want to get shot
in the face
God always trust your gut by the way
when you said your sister had a watch
yeah I was kind of hoping for something
a little more
this guy named Chad Davis folks said he
went crazy and made you know a bomb
six people died right yeah including
Chad Davis yeah
six dead only five Shadows
you know what this Creator reminds me
up no idea I'm not I don't care
shoes do you need a plastic bag to
breathe into do you have medication nope
do you need to be on it probably do you
have PTSD I don't think so are you going
completely mental I can stop do you want
me to stop how come I said stop doing
that I'm sweating you're gonna freak me
out
leave it to kids
that's all this about
Debbie to get this woman
my God
[Music]
are you crazy
walked right into this one I've dated
hotter chicks than you
oh
She's creepy
[Music]
oh man
what is the point of that
and what I told you about bullies
you like that Westworld
cover her ass
me saving your life if you do someone a
solid don't be a yacht right just play
it cool otherwise you come off grandiose
unlike you
oh
almost here is an accountant for the
roxon Oil Corporation if your president
calls me in the next half minute Tom
lives
today is your glory let's begin
we gotta get out of here we gotta get
out of here
[Music]
um
your bomb's not a bomb when it's a
misfire stuff doesn't always work right
pal
it's faulty but you found a buyer didn't
you sold it to the Mandarin
kellyanne built that think tank on
Military contracts that's exactly what
we used to do
hi good evening
Maya's in on it little [ __ ]
so you want to tell me why you're at
Stark's Mansion last night I'm trying to
fix this thing I didn't know you and the
master were going to blow the place up
oh I see so you were trying to save
Stark when he threatened I've told you
kylian we can use him
um
I'm confused is she evil or good
happy to help no need to think it's my
pleasure
seven I've acquired the Patriot armor
she's a Karen
um it does say Miami Florida okay
capitalizing the Mark 4 too what's
questionable about electricity all right
it's my suit and then I can't I'm not
gonna
why don't you just build something
okay
[Music]
all the crazies are in Florida
oh
[Music]
foreign
did you know that fortune cookies aren't
even Chinese some guy over here they're
made by Americans based on based on the
Japanese recipes hey I see sound like
Austin power years
bloody hell
what
my name's Trevor Trevor Slattery
what are you
don't hurt the face I'm an actor
the Mandarin see it's not real
wow
plot twists
they approached me about the role so you
needed someone to take credit for some
Act accidentally explosions Killian
Killian he created you he created me
you're still going down pal you know
I didn't tell him anything nothing
No Hands give me jack's first
[Music]
spring plot twist I like that that was
different I'm on the street people are
going bang they're painting the walls
Maya you're kidding yourself help me fix
it
did I do that yes I remember the night
not the morning
you used to have ideals
wanted to help people
I get to wake up every morning with
someone who
still has their soul
that was a burn
the second you give evil a face
bin Laden
Gaddafi a mandarin can hand the people
to Target you're something else
but at this moment the body is trying to
decide whether to accept extremists or
just give up and if it gives up I have
to say
let him go
Maya I said let him go
girls will do that
what happens if you go too hot
a high level position has just been
vacated
what
however do not open do not open don't
open don't open all right let's go
Godzilla yeah he does remind me of
Electro trust me you're gonna be
Gonna Be puddled Blood on the ground in
five four three come on two
how did we get this shift
here it comes
three four shut up five four three
I told you
[Music]
up
honestly I hate working here they are so
weird
not this time not to fish
oh that's good to be back ah let's go
ah crap
they're using the Iron Patriot as a
trojan horse they're gonna take out the
president somehow we have to immediately
alert that plane
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
that's really bad
oh my God
13 sir wouldn't you die just from like
the pressure of getting sucked out of a
plane though
oh my God
I hope the y'all can swim
I'd be like
oh my God
[Music]
oh my God
that's awful all our president did was
fall off a bike is that yep
[Music]
here are the three that or four that I
saw it's Christmas
give me church
foreign
see what happens when I hang out with my
ex-girlfriends
such a jerk yeah really oh
stuck feeling stuck
cringy close your eyes you don't want to
see this
aren't they gonna attack her now because
her heat signature
as high bye-bye
oh my God
brace yourself
cheese
that's pretty good you gotta let go I'll
catch you I promise
[Music]
what no but she's got the heat thing in
her though shame
I would have caught her shut up bro he's
pissing me off die [ __ ]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
do me a favor and blow Mark 42
[Music]
that's the way to do it
oh what well good that means pepper is
probably still alive
you love gnome uglier than before you
said you
said
the Mandarin
yes Queen
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
it's he dead now that was really violent
but awesome the Clean Slate protocol sir
screwed it's Christmas yes yes
what
why are you blowing them up
as promised I got pepper sorted out took
some tinkering but then I thought to
myself
why stop there
of course there are people who say
progress is dangerous but I'll bet none
of those idiots ever had to live with a
chest full of shrapnel
neither will I oh
[Music]
pieces of his heart shrapnel and her
necklace that's
some Megan Fox MGK stuff right there
[Music]
how do you explain that to your parents
[Music]
my armor
it was never a distraction or a hobby
it was a cocoon
a changed man I thought he was gonna say
I'm a butterfly
one thing you can't take away I am Iron
Man
yes you are all right I'm gonna watch
the
post credits
I had no idea you're such a good
listener Toyota
share all my intimate thoughts my
experiences with someone it just cuts
the weight of it in half you know it's
like a snake swallowing its own tail
where did I lose you
elevator in Switzerland
so you heard none of it I'm not a
therapist it's not my training I don't
have the what the time
temperament
oh God my original wound 1983. all right
yeah 14 years old I still have a nanny
that was weird
I love it I love it okay never mind I'm
seeing at the end it does say Paramount
so I guess this still was Paramount when
did Disney I thought the Avengers was
Disney though and this came after the
Avengers
I'm confused I'm very confused okay
so thoughts I definitely liked it better
than the second one I would say first
one still is my top second one I'm so
sorry you're my bottom this one it's
interesting it it kept my attention very
entertaining
um I like that Tony Stark kind of got
his you know he got his thing back he's
definitely worn himself in this movie
than he was in the second movie I love
Pepper Potts in this movie because I
love that she had her little badass
moment at the end I really enjoyed that
and seeing his face was priceless
um yeah they're so cute I love them in
this movie I feel like I did there were
so many twists so many twists and turns
this felt like a five act movie
it was a lot I felt like it had like
multiple endings and uh it was a lot the
action in this movie was really great I
did think the dialogue was a lot better
in this movie than it was in the second
one it felt the tone felt more like the
first one so I really really happy about
that all the performances in this movie
were amazing honestly I I think everyone
did such a good job reacting in this
movie there were so many similarities
though okay peep this Spider-Man yeah
he's kind of my dude so I even though
I'm not up on all the Marvel movies or
anything like that I'm a huge Spider-Man
fan I've been since day one with Toby as
a kid those movies are so nostalgic for
me so I've always kept up at least with
the Spider-Man movies and I felt like
there were so many aspects about this
movie that reminded me of The Amazing
Spider-Man 2. this movie came out before
the amazing surrounding two by like one
year and then right after that right
after this movie came out then it was
Amazing Spider-Man 2 and I know Sony did
that one so I don't know if that they
like had this some similar people
working on it or like I don't know there
was the villains and even the way that
the skin looked underneath it reminded
me a lot of Electro
and the same kind of origin story not
really but like a very uh similar type
character even though the character in
The Amazing Spider-Man 2 was not a
genius I really love the twist about the
Mandarin just being an actor that was
like probably one of the best parts of
the movie in my opinion
um all of the Iron Man's coming together
at the end was it was a lot it was a lot
I don't know why he decided to get rid
of all of them I feel like the endings
of last two Iron Man movies felt similar
and that you don't know how they're
gonna get out of it but then all of a
sudden poof something comes in and saves
him technically and also the guy just
like Wouldn't Die I hate that I don't
understand the science behind him being
exploded inside of a suit not killing
him but then another explosion killing
him it's a movie but I didn't understand
the science behind like okay they're
very hot people temperature wise like
some explosions would make them die or I
don't know and then others wouldn't
kind of gave me a headache yeah so I
didn't really get that sometimes it was
a little messy at the end I kind of wish
the ending
was meshed together a little better but
I really did enjoy this movie it did
feel a little long I feel like the only
part about it that I felt like they
could have completely done without was
the whole airplane sequence the reason
why I say that something about it like
kind of rubbed me the wrong way I was an
American because with the Avengers they
had all these buildings getting you know
destroyed in New York City my thought
was that was kind of done in bad taste
like why I know his Tower was in New
York City but like why not have put that
in LA or like downtown L.A because
having 911 you know still it just I
don't know I thought that was kind of in
bad taste and then seeing the airplane
sequence
and being reminded again of like 9 11
and stuff it just I didn't like that I
didn't like that part it didn't really
add that much like they could have just
taken the president
from somewhere else it just I know they
it was cool when he saved all the people
and I really enjoyed that moment but
that's also was that like a pothole for
people am I just not like him being able
to be there but not be there physically
I'm like could he have just done that at
the end as well to save pepper pods like
have another suit you know fighting them
or something I don't know that I got a
little confused about that part to be
honest yeah I I don't know the science
behind that either yeah I guess it is
kind of hard dealing with the whole
topic of like terrorists and stuff like
that especially as Americans and what
we've witnessed over the years so I mean
I think the
um again the Mandarin being the actor
was like my favorite part about any
twist in this movie hated the villain
really did
he's no Loki but I loved loved loved
Robert Downey Jr in this movie and the
kid that helped him was adorable I loved
their Dynamic I hope he comes back in
other movies
a kid or something like that would be
cool if he ended up I don't know working
for
Stark that would be really nice so I
don't know I haven't seen I haven't seen
any of the other Avengers movies so have
no idea but that would be cool the first
half of this movie I just I thought was
really really great and I I kind of did
like it happened around the holidays
um something about that there was a lot
of heart in this movie that's what I
wanted to say I felt like there was a
lot of heart in this movie
um it seemed like the themes and
everything really flowed well together
and a lot of callbacks in the script
that I enjoyed at the very end I really
liked I enjoyed the heart of this movie
for sure it got me my feels
I thought it was very well done it will
last me a little bit at the end
um with all of the
Transformers I mean Iron Man so cool
though so cool why didn't you wear the
black suit that black suit was like sick
the black suit with a gold on it
change it up dude because that was cool
I would have loved to have seen him in
that interesting
and there's not an Iron Man 4 right so
it's like it
I'm just kind of sad because I like
these movies I do I love the characters
but anyway I'm excited to see the new
Avengers movies what is it Age of Ultron
yeah I have it written down all right
I can't wait to watch Avengers Age of
Ultron with you guys I have no idea what
that means
at all so thanks again for watching
thanks for listening to my rambling
review
I uh wish I was a little more articulate
tonight I'm sorry I'm headache and yeah
if you enjoyed this video at all please
give it a like and if you want to see
when my next reaction is up please hit
that notification Bell it'll let you
know when my next one is up and also
Greg and John have a bunch of other
videos on this channel if you want to
stay tuned and check out some more
you'll be thoroughly entertained so
thanks so much for watching and see you
next time bye
foreign
[Music]